the fire ox is the first instantiation
of a vehicle that's geared towards first
responders in this case particularly
firefighters you can remote control the
vehicle like a large toy car where you
take literally a game style controller
and drive the vehicle remotely where you
want to go but you don't actually have
to be on the vehicle
we have a large water tank on the system
we have a remote control nozzle we also
have a pump we have the ability to
dispense water while the vehicle is
moving this machine can be used to fight
wildland fire to get into situations
where you have tricky winds or areas
where a shifting fire is also very
useful for high-risk structure fire
situations you can use it in situations
where it's too risky to put the
firefighters in close proximity to the
fire or to other hazardous materials the
development of the fire arcs has not
been nearly that expensive we actually
repurposed a base vehicle that we sent
to Afghanistan and got back in one piece
because this is a variant of a prototype
that's not really in production yet
there's a real challenge for my team to
figure out how to build small numbers of
these vehicles at an affordable cost
that first responders could buy we see a
time when these systems will save lives
to help prevent injuries if we can
figure out how to do more with less how
you could let the machine do the work of
some of the firefighters then you can
help them where they are so challenged
on their budget from